- I can't believe I'm unwrapping an Oreo.
- [Voiceover] Raspberry.
- Raspberry.
- Wait, it doesn't look like an Oreo.
- Yeah, what is that?
- This is not a
conventionally-shaped Oreo.
This is a little turd.
- It matches my cast.
- Do ya think this is less calories?
- Mmm.
- Oh, come on!
That's horrible.
- Daddy like-y.
- The cream is too chalky to be cream.
- This texture would go great with
yogurt or ice cream.
- It tastes like if Oreo
made a children's medicine.
- Blueberry Oreo.
- Blueberry.
These are also soft cookies.
- Soft cookies?
Oreos are not soft.
- There's a surprise waiting
in the middle for us.
- So it's soft but what is that?
- Blueberry rare cheese.
- Rare cheese?
Hmmm.
- I feel like I bit into a jelly bean.
- This is like a diet cookie
with all the calories.
- This is not an Oreo.
- I feel like this is
such a gentle dessert.
They're not trying to overwhelm
me with any one ingredient.
- I don't like that.
- What the fuck, Garrett?
These are great!
- Ooh, chestnut!
- Eww, chestnut!
- Well, these are festive.
- This is sadder than
when, like, the hard Oreos
crumble apart 'cause it's just like...
- It smells like a mistake.
- They melt in your mouth.
- Oh my God, I like it.
It kinda tastes like coffee Oreos.
- I feel like I'm eating
an artisanal Oreo.
- I will say that the
more I eat it the more
I'm like, "Yeah, I
could eat this forever."
- This best one I've had.
- What is milk--
- Milk white chocolate?
- They're so pretty.
It looks like a little tent.
- This is one bite.
- They're like Oreo sticks.
- Do people in Japan
just like tiny things?
- Yeah.
- This smells like a cheesecake.
- Ooh.
- It's all right.
I like the soft cookies better.
- If this were a lotion,
I'd rub it on my body.
- Best thing so far.
- More soft cookies.
- I'm gonna eat all of this.
- Still don't know how
you dunk any of this.
- Okay, here's the thing is that they're
not a bad cookie, they're just not Oreos.
- My overall thought is that
I'm happy to be an American.
- Delicious and nutritious.
- Certainly not either of those things.
- I love this.
This is like just the
right amount of sweetness.
- I would rather eat the normal "American"
Oreos than any of these.
- I wanna go to Japan.
- You wanna go to Japan?
- I do.
- Buddy trip to Japan!
- Love yourself Oreo.
Love yourself.
You're beautiful just the way you are.
- I'm using chopsticks
in honor of Japanese--
- Oh, I wanna use chopsticks.
- I brought them from home.
- You did?
- Yeah, I brought them from my desk.
- This guy.